[Music]
hello everyone it is seven o'clock here
in the uk you are very welcome
to spend your breakfast with us wherever
you're watching us this morning we're
expecting a major announcement from
nissan very shortly
which will allow its sunderland plant to
increase production of electric vehicles
we'll be live there to speak to the
business secretary quasi quatern
class arms at the ready with a third of
us set to get a third
covid jab alongside the winter flu
vaccine
also this morning for you one of the
biggest live shows on earth
is back we'll hear about the return of
the edinburgh
fringe festival and it's definitely
not a bird or a plane we'll speak to one
of the designers of a flying car
which has just completed its maiden
flight let's hope
they're not winging it it's thursday the
1st
of july picture punch a clean set of
wheels nissan is expected to announce
plans for a giant
factory to build batteries for electric
vehicles and create
thousands of new jobs
the crumbling city a warning for the
world about the effects of climate
change on the bangladeshi capital dhaka
people who don't believe that climate
change is happening are totally ignorant
closing the gap the clothing retailer
abandons its high street stores in the
uk and moves online
conviction overturned criticism as the
actor bill cosby maintains his innocence
on his release from jail
brothers reunited princes william and
harry will come together to unveil a
statue of their mother
on what would have been her 60th
birthday later on today
and we start off july with the same
weather that we ended june on
will it brighten up and become drier
into the weekend i'll have the details
for you later
[Music]
morning everybody within the next half
an hour we're expecting the japanese car
giant
nissan to unveil plans to build a huge
battery factory
to boost production of electric vehicles
and create 2
000 jobs at its sunderland plant
our business correspondent paul kelso is
there for us hello to you
paul so tell us more about this project
yeah good morning kay we are expecting
some good news
certainly for uh the future of the
sunderland nissan
factory where i am this morning we don't
have the details yet we'll be getting
them
in about 20 minutes time but the
expectation is
a major new facility adjacent to this
site to build
batteries that will power the next
generation of electric vehicles we know
the government has said by 2030
that petrol and diesel engine cars new
petrol and diesel engine cars
will be banned so there is a pressure to
move
to electric cars and this investment the
scale of which we don't
yet know but expected to be certainly
the largest planned
battery factory so-called gigafactories
in the phrase used
coined by elon musk will be built here
they already build an electric vehicle
here the nissan leaf certainly the
short-range version
of that the first all-electric mass
production car nissan call it they
already make that here and there's a
battery plant adjacent to this
site which produces those but this will
be a much bigger investment and it will
not only secure
the jobs that are already here at this
plant but should create new
jobs and perhaps signal the start of the
move towards mass production of electric
cars
that's so vital to hitting net zero
targets and you can expect
ministers all the way to the top to be
all over this announcement it's good
news for
the northeast and it will be hailed as
good news for the uk okay
now thank you thanks so much uh and i'm
going to be uh chatting uh very shortly
indeed to the minister involved we'll
hear from the nissan bosses as well as a
news conference in sunderland
as i said uh quasi quartens speaking to
us at 7
20. half the population could be offered
a coveted booster this winter the nhs is
preparing to administer
extra shots alongside its regular flu
vaccine programme what is that going to
look like let's speak to visiting
professor of microbiology
at the university of oxford and advisor
to the government's vaccine task force
and that's geoffrey almond hello to you
thank you for joining us professor
this morning let me just ask you first
of all more and more people
um it would appear who have been double
jabbed uh contracting covid
what difference will a booster make
well it will only help and uh there are
there are quite a number of vaccines
that we give as three doses most of the
childhood vaccines we give as three
doses it gives a
boost to the immune system uh raises the
levels of antibodies and makes that
protection
even more secure so in principle it's
a good idea of course there are issues
around supply
who gets it and also questions about
about availability of vaccine into the
winter given that the world is still
crying out for it so this is an
ambitious program
in principle excellent but practically
um
perhaps a bit more of a challenge okay
and how are you feeling about mixing and
matching vaccines
no problem at all we have a lot of
vaccines
currently that we take that mixes that
are mixes and matches
in childhood we typically give
diphtheria tetanus and pertussis
together sometimes we
add polio and hemophilus
to that so combination vaccines are
have been with this for a long long time
of course you try
you need to do trials to make sure that
when you do mix
um you know you get the appropriate
responses
uh mixing across companies so if you've
had pfizer and then you go to
astrazeneca
or or vice versa again not a problem
you're going to provoke
an immune response that will be a boost
these vaccines are similar enough
to be able to reinforce each other so i
have no
no problems at all with that in fact
there may even be some advantages to
that
and how are you feeling about kids being
vaccinated
well you know we keep hearing from
ministers don't we about you know
70 80 percent of the adult population
is being in as being jabbed that's good
but the real figure that's important
is what proportion of the whole
population at the start of this we
reckon that you needed
somewhere around 65 70 percent of the
population the whole population to be
immune in order to have that herd
immunity which prevents the virus
spreading
now since then we've got these rather
more transmissible variants
particularly the delta so maybe that
figure's
gone up to around 70 because it has a a
bigger r number our zero number
um and you know therefore we have to
think about vaccinating the
kids um because eighty percent of the
adult population if that only represents
50
of the whole population we're still too
low to prevent the virus spreading and
it will spread in kids so
i i'm in favor if we can and when we can
of vaccinating children as well so that
the whole population
is immune to the point where the virus
can no longer circulate
and how are you feeling professor about
um suggestions after the 19th of july
terminus day as it's
been called that we're just going to
have to live with covid and it's just
going to be part of our society like
pneumonia or the flu
well that's probably the reality um
again if we can get the herd immunity up
by vaccination
to very high levels then any outbreaks
might be quite localized and won't
spread across the country
um and i think yeah clearly
kovid will be with us for quite a long
time we've got to get used to it we do
have outbreaks
of course of other virus infections in
the winter
um flu notably but also
what we call rhinoviruses common cold
respiratory insitial virus
they come around every winter and
perhaps perhaps uh kovid will be the
same
it's worth observing however that the
serious pandemics
of the 20th century 1918 57
68 etc uh which were in fact all flew
in the first wave the first year
those viruses those pandemics were quite
severe with a lot of deaths
as they went on although those same
viruses with changes
continued to circulate they became
attenuated they were less
uh virulent in the population and caused
less deaths and it may be
that when we're vaccinated and we've
seen covid
before if we do get infected in the
future
it may well be that it's significantly
more mild than it has been on this first
wave of infections in the human
population okay
fascinating stuff professor thanks for
taking the time to join us this morning
thank you
you're very welcome okay bye-bye um the
bangladeshi capital of dhaka
is said to be crumbling officials there
are warning it could become a security
problem for the whole world
with the risk of tens of millions of
so-called climate migrants
bangladesh with a population of more
than 163 million people is facing a
climate emergency last year alone
saw more than four million people
displaced caused by intense flooding
which continues to devastate villages
and farmland worsening
an already dire situation of rural
poverty in the country
during monsoon season at least a quarter
of bangladesh found itself
submerged it's a problem that's growing
at an alarming rate by 2050
its estimated sea levels could rise by
half a metre
washing away 11 of the country's land
with homes schools
and in some cases entire villages fading
away due to land erosion
many find they have no other choice but
to migrate to dhaka
they join up to 2 000 people who make
the journey into the capital every day
searching for better living conditions
and new opportunities
but it's a city already struggling to
cope with a growing population of nearly
22 million
bangladesh's government has told sky
news that climate migration could create
a global refugee crisis in the first in
a series of special reports from
bangladesh
katherine vitozi has been to dhaka where
climate displaced people are now trapped
in slums in a cycle of debt and poverty
in kalyan poor slum there are no road
names
just alleyway numbers
it's dark dirty and a
side of climate change you don't expect
and rarely see
every year climate change is forcing
half a million bangladeshis from their
rural homes
most end up in dakar city slums
where space is running out salaam
alaikum
no jahan begum arrived last year from
the coast with her family
she tells us they had a small farm but
now they're renting
a two-room shack with no windows
and barely enough room to move
but this
bangladesh is on the climate change
front line
it's geographically vulnerable to rising
sea levels and stronger cyclones
most climate migrants were fishermen or
farmers
they've seen their homes livelihoods
even their land
disappear
from
until then they're stuck in a place
where landlords
some with political connections charge
high prices for unsafe homes
electricity is connected illegally
sewers flood when it rains
[Music]
but what use is a dustpan against
monsoon rain
and a drain put in to help does the
reverse
that brings the water but that's
bringing the water in you want the water
to go the other way
yes and the water is dirty he says it
smells
dhaka is now the most crowded city in
the world
[Music]
on the verge of yet another strict
covert 19 lockdown
thousands of migrant workers have
escaped for their rural homes
climate change migrants don't have that
option
foreign
over the last 20 years bangladesh has
lifted millions of people
out of poverty
at the capitals main port you can see
the trade and industry that has expanded
the economy
grown the middle class but also drawn
people to a city that now can't cope
daca is crumbling that guy's crumbling
under under people coming here
and do you think this is the side of
climate change that people just don't
see and don't realize exists yeah they
don't connect
uh this reality with climate change
because
because they think it's coastal areas
this is uh this is something that's
gonna happen in the future
but this is dystopia this is happening
in real time and i think the world
doesn't know enough about it
but people here can't just wait
she understood english are you
understanding
in one alleyway we meet tanya akhtar
who's 18.
her family moved here to escape rising
sea levels
she hopes this small school run on the
family bed
can somehow do something i
teaches them english bengali
math they are
they doesn't speak english
i am little i'm little but i try my best
to teach them
this is minara this is tanya's mother
and she wanted to tell us how proud she
felt of her daughter for
doing this teaching but she wanted to
try and say it in english so
tandy is doing a little bit of impromptu
teaching as well
so that she can say on camera of how
proud she is of her daughter
do you want to say it
tell us how you feel about your daughter
i feel proud
i feel proud proud
to my daughters to my daughter
in climate change there are tipping
points a moment from where
there is no return people here want to
go back
home but to what for many
this is now their future
category sky news daca
and a reminder you can watch the daily
climate show on sky news every weekday
at 6 30
and 9 30. still to come on the program
for you we're going to be talking to
royal historian robert lacy as princes
william and harry prepared to unveil a
statue
marking what would have been their
mother's 60th birthday today that's at
half a seven
the government will reduce furlough and
business rates relief from today labor
says more than four hundred thousand
businesses will be affected
bridget phillips and the shadow chief
secretary to the treasury joins us at
five past eight
and then at half thursday we'll speak to
labour mp stellar creasy
on why she is challenging the
parliamentary authorities
about her maternity leave
fashion retailer gap has announced it's
to close all of its shops in britain and
move completely
online uh shiman freeman pallet is at
one of its stores in oxford street here
in london for us this morning hello t
shimon
this must mean a lot of jobs at risk
yes it does as we know it's going to be
a huge
loss to the high street gap is an
american companies but it's been
in the uk since 1987 and this morning
it announced that it will be closing all
81
of its stores in a move to take its
business online now
81 stores may not sound like a lot but
it does have a huge presence
on the high street if you think about
the local gap in your local area they
usually are quite
big shops so it will really hit workers
hard
um they are saying that it's been a part
of a review where it was reviewing all
of its european stores it's not clear
what's going to be happening to them but
we do know that here in the uk
they will be closed in in what gap are
describing as a phase manner
from the end of august until the end of
september so it doesn't
give them very long at all the union
leader paddy liddis he's a
union leader for shop workers he's
described it as a devastating move
and he also referenced the closures of
arcadia
and debenhams and said that as far as he
concerned
it proves that there needs to be
government intervention and that the
government needs to speak to unions
and workers to try and come up with a
plan of getting more sort of online
taxes
so that they can save the high street
okay thank you
also making news for you this morning on
the program large-scale celebrations
have been taking place
to mark the 100th birthday of the ruling
chinese communist party
leaders attended a parade in beijing
where the president vowed that china
would complete
reunification with taiwan
donald trump's company and its finance
chiefs have been
indicted on tax related crimes it
follows an investigation by officials
in new york into how the trump
organization gave
non-monetary benefits such as apartments
and cars
to top executives mr trump has said such
dealings are
standard practice
and the former united states defense
secretary donald rumsfeld
has died at the age of 88. the former
president george bush described him
as a man who never paled before tough
decisions
he became famous for his quotes such as
this one during a press conference in
washington
there are known knowns there are things
we know we know
we also know there are known unknowns
that is to say we know there are some
things we do not know
but they're also unknown unknowns the
ones we don't know
we don't know excuse me but is this an
unknown unknown
uh i'm not several unknowns and i'm just
wondering i'm not saying i'm not gonna
say which it is
okay uh we're telling you at the top of
the hour with the car giant nissan is uh
announcing a so-called
gigafactory at its plant in sunderland
to produce batteries to power electric
vehicles well let's speak to the
business secretary quasi kuatang who is
at the nissan plant in sunderland this
morning good morning to you thank you
for joining us on the programme this
morning
um is nissan a good candidate for uh
state
age now or have you helped them enough
already
i think nissan's investigating here in
sunderland
is a really really good news story uh
i've been
conversing with nissan executives also
within vision
uh who are making uh the battery the the
gigafactory that you described
and this is a really positive story for
the uk we're delighted that
they're going to be creating uh 1 600
new jobs
between them these are very well paid
jobs and i think it's an excellent
uh development for here in the northeast
and also for the uk
will we give them more money if they
need it via state aid
we are in conversation with them as with
other companies
and they feel that this is exactly the
right place
uh to invest in we're very very keen to
develop that relationship
and it's a very good one for the uk and
also for people
here in the northeast so if they did
come to the government and say look we
need a bit more money in order to
develop this further for the future
then they they would be pushing at an
open door
i wouldn't say that they're pushing at
an open door we always look
to get a good investment in terms of
taxpayers money
but they have a very good relationship
with us
they've been here since 1986 and they
want
to commit to this plant for decades to
come
okay why electric cars over synthetic
fuel
i think electric cars have proven uh
their green credentials uh they're
popular people
are buying them in increasing numbers
and it's really the way of the future
and that's why
uh nissan are investing so heavily
here in the northeast and that's why
that many countries
competitive advanced economies are
seeking to attract
this kind of investment to build
gigafactories
so that they can build electric vehicles
these are the
the transport of the future you're not
you're not dismissing synthetic fuel
though are you
dismissing any decarbonized
source of fuel in fact the synthetic
aviation uh fuel synthetic aviation fuel
is something that we're very
keen to promote uh here in the uk and
we're looking at all sorts of
technologies to drive uh very low carbon
uh transport okay we've only got five
minutes so we'll counter through another
couple of points if we may this nhs
app we were told it was perfect to
confirm double vaccinations for people
who wanted to go on overseas holidays
i'm sure you saw what happened
with people who were trying to go to
malta yesterday they were told that the
app is just
not good enough and they had to leave
the airport and go
home what on earth is going on what are
we going to do about that
well we're trying to engage uh as you
know with
uh countries across the eu we feel that
uh the double vaccination does provide
really really first-class
uh support and protection against uh the
variants
that all the evidence suggests that and
we need to speak to
eu governments and other countries to
make that case
i don't know what happened well i do
know what happened in multiple i don't
know what the process
was for the maltese government to get to
reach that decision
uh but it's something that we clearly
have to engage uh with other governments
across the eu and and across the world
but people are going
to show up sorry to interrupt you i know
on speaker which makes it slightly
difficult and we're also pushed for time
but people who are going on holiday
today they should still be confident
that if they've
got their two vaccinations on their nhs
app that should be good enough
to fly to their chosen holiday
destination
obviously it should be but i can't
guarantee what other
uh governments are going to do um like
the maltese government but i i
if i were a traveler i'd be very
confident that i'd be able to
go to my destination without any
hindrance
when can parents be confident that their
children
can be vaccinated against kovid 19 will
it be
now or will we have to wait until
september
well the um the jcvi have
made very clear uh that they haven't uh
actually given the clearance for
children uh to be vaccinated we've
successfully vaccinated something like
uh 45 million first doses
for over 18s but we're still waiting for
uh confirmation that we can vaccinate
children until
uh that happens uh we're not going to
vaccinate children
okay and a final thought before i let
you go 400 scottish fans at wembley
when they came down for the game against
england have now tested
positive what impact is that going to
have on the scheme that the government
is presently
uh running and and specifically the euro
2020 final at wembley
as far as the government is concerned
that will still go ahead despite the
fact that there's this massive
outbreak absolutely but the key to the
outbreak the key to dealing with the
coronavirus
is the vaccination so i'd urge anyone
who hasn't been vaccinated to get
their first dose anyone over and people
should be encouraged to get the second
dose that's what's giving us
the protection that we need to fight
this terrible
virus come the 19th of july are you
going to ditch your mask
i'm going to see what the garden says i
mean clearly
people find many people find the mask
sometimes difficult to wear but it is
the guidance i think we should follow
the guns
to keep ourselves safe and more
importantly to keep others
safe as well more vulnerable people
okay i know that you have to flee so i
must let you go it's good to talk to you
thank you very much indeed for joining
us from sunderland this morning thank
you
thank you very much thanks a lot now
there's a new top dog in number 11
downing street this morning alongside
the chancellor rishi sunak has revealed
on twitter that he has a new pet
he simply wrote meet nova it's a thought
nova is a golden
labrador i'm not sure she is
uh just uh too soon to say if he'll get
on with larry the office cat next door
do you remember
we'll try and find a quote for you he
was on the programme at the end of last
year
saying that he was going to give in and
let the kids have a dog
and there you are there he is i think
he's is he i'm not sure he's a golden
lab
you probably know better let me know
quick look at the weather for you now
here's now's morning nurse
good morning you would definitely know
okay but uh
i definitely don't know whatever it is
it's definitely cute
uh looking kind of cute for the weather
today as well not for everywhere though
some areas are going to be rather cloudy
and cool again
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning so for the first day of
july we
are going to see similar conditions as
the last day of june once again
most places will be fine dry and warm
with some good spells of sunshine
developing this afternoon but not
everywhere it's the east once again that
will be plagued with cloudy skies
and light rain and drizzle is quite a
murky start out there this morning as
well
with also some patches of mist and fog
but
mainly dry brightening up into this
afternoon quite quickly
and in the sunshine it will feel warm
but some showers are likely across
southern parts of england and
wales and for the southeast of ireland
some of them could be quite heavy
particularly around the dorset and
hampshire area and it stays cloudy and
cool around
eastern parts of england
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
princess william and harry will unveil a
statue of their mother on what would
have been her 60th birthday today royal
historian robert lacy joins us next
[Music]
they have breached the road there is a
lot of
gas being fired all around us
[Music]
it is an absolute carnival kind of
atmosphere
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
the roads have been inundated the only
way out
is to get people by boat
what is fear that over 200 people might
have died because of these landslides
[Music]
this on any given day would have been
bustling with people but today
it's absolutely deserted
this is one of the most sensitive areas
of of northeast delhi where there's been
clashes
i'm never lazarus and i'm skies reporter
based in delhi
[Music]
hello my name is nadja frantier my name
is ryan matthews
i'm the marine assistant at rather a
research station which is to the west
of the west antarctic peninsula
so far i've been here for five months
and it is an absolutely wonderful
[Music]
experience
my name is fatima zazile the founder of
ikestaff from kuwait where we face many
environmental
problems related to waste pollution the
frustration
and lack of information we are
collecting recyclables from houses
schools and businesses in order to
recycle them
in exchange if you recycle to get a
treat
[Music]
hello again everybody the car firm
nissan has announced it will build a
factory to make batteries for electric
vehicles in sunderland
the company claims the so-called
gigafactory will eventually create more
than six
thousand jobs a short time ago the
business minister
kwateng told the programme the scheme
would provide a major economic
boost electric cars have proven
their green credentials they're popular
people are
buying them in increasing numbers and
it's really the way of the future and
that's why
nissan are investing so heavily here in
the northeast
and that's why that many countries
competitive
advanced economies are seeking to
attract
this kind of investment to build
gigafactories
uh so that they can build electric
vehicles these are the
the transport of the future tamara's
here but will they get state aid well
okay i think the question is how much
have they had already because nissan
putting a billion pounds into building
this factory be up and running by 2024
supplying batteries for 100 000 electric
cars a year so a big expansion of what
they're doing already in sunderland
as the government say good news
post-brexit jobs and so on
have the government put in some of that
money quasi quarten was a little bit
tight-lipped
when you asked him will they be eligible
for the new state aid regime going
forward he said they wouldn't be pushing
at an
open door so trying not to sound as if
they're favoring
nissan but that will be the question i
think asked about how much
money they will get or have had already
from government
but one of the biggest investments in
the northeast since the 1980s so good
news there and britain
catching up with rivals in france and
germany on electric cars because don't
forget
new petrol and diesel cars will be
banned you won't be able to buy one
after 2030 so the investment in electric
cars
really does need to scale up yeah
synthetic feel though important
as well i'm sure we can develop that
argument as the weeks and months
progress
just a quick thought on the app though i
mean he wasn't very helpful
on whether people turning up at the
airport today can just use their app to
show that they've been double vaccinated
in order to travel overseas on holiday
no the problem these holidaymakers have
had in malta booking those holidays in
good faith after it went on
the green list is they took their nhs
app and we're told you need to have a
printed out
letter which tells me to get which takes
five days to get so their holidays
have been ruined and if different
countries are going to impose
uh different restrictions that really
does change things regarding
the green list yeah ranch chaps that
i'll really need to get their act
together on that especially if people
are hoping to travel for the first time
in maybe 18 months or whatever and they
don't know whether they get to the
airport whether they'll be able to go
absolutely holiday kids suitcases
aggravation from everybody
nightmare for now thanks a lot thank you
quick look at the front pages for you
uh this morning this is what it's
looking like the time says half the
population will be offered a third
coronavirus jab alongside the winter flu
vaccine from september
the mail also leads on that booster
program which will be offered to the
over 50s
the telegraph says that downing street
has told head teachers to stop
sending whole school bubbles home to
self-isolate when just one pupil tests
positive for covid
and the guardian questions the safety of
hosting the final stages of euro 2020 at
wembley
after hundreds of scottish fans who
traveled to london for the match against
england tested positive
for covert the minister said that it
would still go ahead
the mirror reports princes william and
harry are putting aside
their differences to unveil a statue of
their mother princess
diana well the royal historian robert
lacy
is joining us now hello to mr lacey
thanks for joining us on the programme
this morning the boys are going to be
together later on what's that going to
be like
they're going to be just over there i
can tell you that what's that going to
be like
um uh
obviously they're here to to pay tribute
to their mother
and that will presumably be reflected in
in
in what they say they're going to make
separate speeches
this will all be under the auspices of
their uncle charles spencer with their
their two aunts um it would be very much
a spencer occasion even if
we were not so focused on the two of
them i think
this opening of the statue here to diana
it's not the first monument in
kensington to
to her there's a there's a there's a
playground a walkway
a fountain this was planned by the
brothers as the
the ultimate tribute members of the
public i think from tomorrow will be
able to walk around there and look at it
through the hedge and then if you pay
some extra you can actually go into the
palace and see it
it's going to be a short ceremony two
o'clock this afternoon only half an hour
allowed a couple of cameras
they want to keep it private uh indeed
so
it we know that it's been a very
strained uh relationship between the two
brothers since that
oprah interview some suggestions in the
papers that that has
warmed up somewhat when the boys were
chatting about football over the last
couple of days what's your understanding
of what's going on
well the the breakdown in the
relationship went way beyond um back
before the the
the the oprah interview that of course
has made things worse
because of what harry said an almost
calculated
attack on his father prince charles and
the parenting he's so resented he said
um the other insidious thing about the
oprah interview was that
um and what in in
in the days that followed was the way in
which private conversations between
harry and the family got repeated on
american television
now that rather undermines negotiations
or talks
um coming back together if if william on
his side feels that anything he says
is going to find its way uh into the
into the media
then how is he going to have a a serious
conversation about
patching things up what role if any is
their father going to play today
no role for prince charles no role for
the queen um
this does mark um as i was saying a
a big stage in the specification if you
like
of the royal family some people would
say what we're looking at
is a row between a redheaded spencer and
his equally hot-headed
brother and so it's appropriate really
that uncle charles
and the two aunts will be here and um
well one runs out of cliches oil on
troubled waters some sort of gesture
towards each other
people say well what would happen if
diana were
present today well she will be present
this afternoon
physically we'll see what this statue
looks like
and of course she will be in the minds
and hearts of those
two young men and presumably that will
influence
their behavior towards each other
they'll be conscious that although there
are only a few cameras there
the eyes of the world will be upon them
and by this evening
we'll know more um um robert a quick
thought about
uh the statue one wonders how it will uh
stand the test of time i think
particularly
i'm not too far away from where you're
standing at the moment and the
diana water memorial i mean that's been
a bit of a white elephant hasn't it
yes um we've got right here um a statue
of queen victoria as well
um statues are rather um
out of fashion at the moment um but uh
the brothers thought
that's what they wanted to do for um
years ago what's interesting
is apparently she's not just standing
there she's doing something that
symbolizes
what she diana stood for whether there's
another figure a child she's reaching
out to
we don't know so that will be very
interesting this afternoon
along with the way the two brothers
react not just to the statue which
they've chosen themselves
um but to each other okay uh robert two
o'clock this afternoon we'll know more
for now thank you for your expertise
appreciated
thank you thank you uh two o'clock this
afternoon is when the statue will be
unveiled both boys will be at that
opening
unveiling ceremony of course we'll cover
it for you here on sky news
meantime police have been heavily
criticized with our handling of two
high-profile public protests one
involved a demonstration
against the government's new crime bill
in bristol earlier this year
let's speak to the police and crime
commissioner for avon and somerset
police and that is mark shelford mr
shelton thank you for joining us on the
program this morning
pretty damning report isn't it for your
police service
well i think it's entirely how uh
healthy that
uh the police should uh face
uh scrutiny and accountability of what
they did
but the um particular riot was a
a unique situation and very difficult
for the police
particularly under the covet 19
legislation
um to not and it did not allow the
public to protest at the time
the forces in the quotes from the um the
report
failed to understand their legal duties
police officers failing to understand
their legal duties in respect of the
protest
and failed to conduct a proper
assessment of the proportionality
of their actions
it's very difficult for the police on
the front line
to be asked to make those sort of legal
uh
judgments and this is an element that i
think is very important
for government and uh our law makers our
mps
to understand when they produce a law
how it will then
be enacted in on the front line
and they always need to think that and
that's something i've been uh talking to
our mps
about to make sure that it minimizes
that amount of
element on the front line where police
have to interpret law
so it's very clear the police should
know the law
and know when they've gone too far
surely
um absolutely and i think that the use
of force was entirely proportionate
at the time when it went from a peaceful
protest to an extremely violent one of
the most violent protests we've seen in
this country
for a long time and people who
peacefully protest don't come
to protest with fireworks in their
pockets to throw out police sources
i mean it was outrageous now um
i think it's terribly important that we
are allowed
to peacefully protest that's our
democratic right it's enshrined
in law but as soon as it become it tips
over into violence and disorder and
assault
then the police need to make sure they
uh
understand the public safety issues and
the police
must absolutely deal with that robustly
as they did
but with proportionate use of force uh
when it was necessary so you completely
disagree with the report when it says
that the police went too far
yes um why
because i think it's uh it was a
proportionate use of force to extremely
violent
protesters uh uh when it when it turned
into a public order situation
so i think the the the police were
absolutely right
but part of my role is to scrutinize and
hold the police accountable
and make sure that the chief constable
has explained absolutely the strategy
around
what they were trying to do at the time
and that
if there were any complaints about
excessive force
those were uh uh and must be thoroughly
investigated
by the police standards uh authority
which they were
and also sent to any complaints were
sent to the
independent office of uh police conduct
uh and those have all come back uh
saying that the police were
uh correct and and and they did use
proportionate fools
for that violent protest but how much
damage then can this
report uh findings do to for as
far as the trust in the police service
in avon and somerset
is concerned how can you start to mend
bridges because
they fundamentally disagree with your
point of view or the way of looking at
is you fundamentally disagree with them
well i think there are two things there
there's there's the strategic issue
around government and the laws which we
talked about earlier on and making sure
those laws are correct and there's no
none of this in the report it talks
about one law trumping another that's
incredibly difficult for frontline
officers to to understand and
i've been on the front line in a
previous existence so i know how
difficult it is when you're in a riot to
try and interpret these rules
that's the first thing and so we need
must make sure that our lawmakers get it
right
but the second aspect is is locally and
i'm new in post
after this instance as you know i've
been in for about six weeks
and it's my job to go round to the
communities which i am doing now
to listen to them to understand what
their concerns are
in the broadest possible terms and then
to work
with them to rebuild that trust
and make sure that we bring in the
police at the right time with the right
people
in the neighborhood groups which are so
vital for pcsos to build that
local relationship with uh people and
understand where there are issues
and how we can try and solve them okay
good to talk to you thanks for
taking the time this morning appreciate
it
my pleasure and my pleasure to be with
you thank you
award-winning chef paul ivich will speak
at a global climate change summit to
explain
how your diet could improve the
environment he joins us next
[Music]
well we know we've got to get rid of
coal you know the world agrees that coal
is the most polluting fossil fuel
we the uk has done great things and more
announcements today
on its coal phase-out acceleration but
the uk is a tiny amount
of global emissions with practically no
coal left in its generation and while we
shut down coal and other european
countries do
countries like china are opening five
times as much
new coal as the rest of the world put
together and we know that many economies
around the world are still very very
coal dependent so
i co-created the ppca the powering past
coal alliance with my good friend in
canada
back in 2017 it's been a really
effective way of getting governments
to pledge to come off coal by 2030
but the challenge is how do you get into
these
giant coal using countries and at the
world business council for sustainable
development our members are drawn from
the most ambitious
global companies who have enormous
supply chains that go
right back into those factories that are
burning coal across the world and so
we'll be working with our members
as part of the ppca to see how we can
use the power of those supply chains the
power of those contracts
to get this coal switch happening faster
companies like apple like google are
very good actually at working with the
local authorities to build renewable
energy plants for example to work out
how to make these changes on the ground
but we haven't been clear
in our view enough about coal we've
focused a lot on the switch to
renewables
then you often get into a row about is
it okay to use
gas as a transitional fuel in the mix
you know i'm sure you know this but the
way we got off coal in the uk which
happened very rapidly
is by standing up gas standing up
biomass
and investing increasingly in renewables
but many countries say well we can't go
straight to a renewable system you can't
as an energy minister i can tell you you
can't run a grid of 100 renewables so
we don't we want to use gas and you're
telling us we can't
so i think sharpening this message to
say yes we want to transition to a
renewables future
but in the meantime let's put coal
firmly in the gun sites and get rid of
that
in short order you know we look at the
carbon dioxide levels they're the
highest they've been for four and a half
million years we need to make coal
history and we need to do it now
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
done
did you know symptoms of hay fever can
develop at any stage of life
not just in childhood the pollen reports
sponsored by philips connected air
purifiers
it'll be sunny for the majority of the
uk and ireland again today
except across eastern england where
it'll stay predominantly cloudy and for
coastal areas of the south and west
there may be a few showers over parts of
wales the south of england and southwest
scotland as well as across the cloudy
east
otherwise it will be mainly dry and warm
pollen levels will be high or very high
for most places today
as we are now in the peak of the grass
pollen season moderate levels are likely
for the eastern side of scotland though
fungal spores are also at a medium risk
and there is lots of weed pollen about
too the pollen reports
sponsored by philips connected air
purifiers
the film star turned environmental
campaigner arnold schwarzenegger
is inviting activists and inventors to a
global summit to discuss ways of
reducing the impact
of climate change well amongst those
taking part is chef paul ivich who is
one of a handful of chefs to have won a
michelin star for
vegetarian cooking and he is with us now
as you can see good morning to you thank
you for joining us
on the programme this morning um tell me
about this summit and what you're doing
there
[Music]
good morning k today
i joined the world australian world
summit it's a great
event and i talk with other peoples
about
the environment and what we can do
why is it so close to your heart
i'm a chef and so it's very important
for me because
when cook when cooking it's not where we
prepare
fish meat or vegetable it's all about
ingredients
that matters it's about respectful
cooperation with the nature
with the animals and the people
when we see foods holistically we can
change a lot
our eating habits affects the
environment
the economy our social lives and our
health
and so it's my desire with my cuisine
to connect to people again with the
nature
how difficult is it or how difficult was
it to get a michelin star for being
a vegetarian chef because you don't
normally associate the two together do
you
yeah it's it's like when you learn a new
language it's
quite hard but if you have a
good passion and a good team so you can
achieve
a lot do you know much about arnold
schwarzenegger do you
have you met him before what are you
expecting from the summit
i expect that he reach a lot of peoples
because
he can achieve billions of people and
i'm very happy that he supports the
austrian summit
because it's very necessary and it's
great
that he do that paul you've been you've
had a love affair with food for most of
your
life what is your advice to young people
who want to be
a vegetarian chef
i just wondered about what your advice
is to young people who want to be a chef
they should be curious and they should
discover the biodiversity of our nature
and
if they have a good passion so
i think that's one of the best jobs you
can have
paul it's fantastic to talk to you i
know you're a very busy man so i must
let you go
thank you very much indeed for joining
us
thank you very much bye-bye bye-bye
bye-bye thank you
i'm so tempted to say i'll be back but i
didn't pet owners in western canada and
the united states are being urged to
take extra care of their pets
during the ongoing heatwave the cochrane
and area humane society in alberta have
decided the best way
to get dogs to drink was by leading them
to an
ice cold paddling pool temperatures
there have continued to break records
with the latest high of 118
degrees fahrenheit remember yesterday we
had bears in the sea trying to
cool down meanwhile this dog owner in
the city of edmonton posted on social
media
how she was now making ice-cold
popsicles to persuade her dog to keep
eating
and drinking during the record-breaking
weather not cute at all is he absolutely
not
oh and uh the champ the chancellor's got
a new dog we'll tell you all about him
in a short time after the weather
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning so today's weather for the
first day of july
the same as the last day of june once
again mostly fine and dry
some showers that could be heavy at
times but not everywhere
but around eastern areas it's cool and
cloudy and there's a lot of missed and
fog around this morning too burning away
quite readily
soon so we will see brighter skies this
afternoon but eastern england
particularly around lincolnshire
east anglia cloudy cool with some rain
some showers across southern areas some
of them could be heavy particularly for
dorset and hampshire
the weather sponsored by qatar airways